you've become in my opinion terrific
actor and not just my opinion a lot of
people's opinion Nebraska
I thought your performance here your
acting performance in Nebraska was
really nuanced there's really terrific
and you do a great job on your own show
last man on earth and what's interesting
to me is you didn't really have a lot of
formal training or you never thought of
yourself as an actor before you
obviously were a funny guy but you
didn't think of yourself as an actor is
that right I was a writer for a long
time I you know I yeah I went to I took
a year of acting at Al Kalani's High
School mr. Gerson but that was it that
you know until I went to the groundlings
in 95 right or something like that
right that's the same thing I did I was
a writer and then I got into the you
know it did some work at The Groundlings
and sort of felt like okay I can use my
writers mind here in a way to get in
front of people yeah but it's
interesting I never I never pursued any
kind of serious acting did you consider
yourself when you were younger like I'd
be a good actor do you think that you
could no I don't think so I always watch
Saturday Night Live and loved it and
always thought oh I would love to be on
that show right and out of I was a
history major at college so I didn't do
any kind of acting but then right after
college I decided like I'm gonna I'm
gonna see if I can try this thing out
and my my buddy had heard me say that
and he was at the UCLA film school so
this guy that he knew was looking for an
actor for this class he was taking at
the television school there and and I
said well I'm an actor and and he said
oh okay well maybe it'll act in my thing
so you know this guy got sold a bill of
goods and that was my first thing that I
ever got to do is this it was called day
of execution and I played this older man
and I'd you know came I brought all my
own stuff and I put a bunch of chalk in
my hair so it seemed gray and it's the
worst thing you've ever seen and I just
found the tape filled by the tape and
this is you doing some this is you're
not proud of this acting you did here
it's the worst acting and for some
reason like it does not say anywhere in
the script
act with a southern accent like I'm just
this this old man with a southern accent
with a bunch of chalk or talcum powder
and it's alright I we have this clip I
have to see it let's take a look at this
first thing first
felling scene I'm gonna kill I gotta go
to the police no why don't you
understand there is nothing to be done I
mean don't you see I can't live with
myself I have to don't you can shut me
up I'll go down there myself I'll tell
the truth I'll talk about you oh man
don't you understand it doesn't matter
rotten is dead I don't care
yeah hey thanks for watching be sure to
click subscribe to see even more great
Conan clips you may now return to your
pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography